[Music]
as you can see the more you around the
more you're going to find out
I'm Dave Ruben this is the Ruben report
it's November 21st 2023 just two days
before Thanksgiving we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share tap that subscription button the
notification bell all the doohickeys do
a little something with each one see
what happens if you want to join us for
a postgame show or if you want to submit
questions so you can join us on our new
call-in show Monday through Thursdays at
1: p.m. people of the internet aptly
titled people of the internet because
you and I are people of the internet uh
you can join us Ruben report. locals.com
and I have to tell you we have a laser
like focused show for you today we are
going to be diving deep into this big
fight between Elon Musk and Media
Matters because it is much bigger than
some rich dude and some crazy leftist
nonprofit organization
it is much more about my ability to talk
to you you guys and your ability to
share videos and stories and Thoughts
with your friends and family online and
how there are organizations that have
been set up mostly Lefty nonprofit
organizations that have been set up to
silence us to make sure some voices
can't be heard to elevate some of the
bad voices to make sure that certain
things that actually are true cannot get
out there and then you'll wonder
why we're in such a wacky situation
where everybody seems to have broken
brains and nobody knows what's really
going on there of course we're going to
connect that to some of the other things
going on in the mainstream media like
MSA MSNBC bringing on a guest who called
for the elimination of Donald Trump
which some might say if that went the
other way there'd be a problem uh and a
whole bunch more before we get to that
let me talk to you guys about my Patriot
Supply guys it's clear the unthinkables
here our most trusted institutions now
deceive us boldly every day this is a
perfect ad for today something's clearly
wrong and it's time to uh and time is
short to become more self-reliant and
secure the future for your family act
today with my Patriot Supply my Patriot
Supply the country's largest
preparedness company is more than
equipped to stock your shelves their
best-selling three-month emergency food
kit provides delicious breakfasts
lunches and dinners that last up to 25
years in storage these kits provide over
2,000 calories every day and are simple
to prepare just add water and heat then
eat make sure every member of your
family has a 3month food kit from my
Patriot Supply you can go right now to
prepare withth ruben.com order by 300
p.m. and your food kit ships fast on the
same day with free shipping it's best to
have emergency food and not need it than
to need it and not have it that's
prepare withth ruben.com prepare withth
ruben.com and now back to me okay so
before we dive into the big thing and
I'm telling you this is the big thing I
know
that there's a lot going on in the world
right now there's a lot going on in
America there's a lot going on in the
Middle East there's a lot going on in
Europe the the planet is a little
wackadoodle at the moment uh but our
ability to talk about how wackadoodle it
is is obviously being somewhat
controlled right now by the powers that
be as it pertains to Big Tech and its
connection uh to the government but
before we dive into that I want to I
want to kind of ease our way into it uh
by talking about the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and uh the
Democrats because there was a
congressman from New York his name is
Dan Goldman uh and he was on Jen saki's
show now of course Jen saki who used to
work for Joe Biden as his press
secretary so she was paid to lie
although I have to say after a year and
a half of Karin jeanpierre the old days
with janaki seemed pretty good right now
but anyway she was paid to lie by the
administration she was unbelievably
horrible at her job which is why we did
so many clips about her and not just us
obviously then she leaves her job to
become a news anchor right a journalist
somehow we're supposed to believe this
woman's a journalist at a televised
mental institution known as MSNBC and
here she is interviewing a Democrat
congressman and you tell me uh if you
think his language here as it relates to
former president Donald Trump is a bit
over the top I want to also turn to
Trump of course and just some of what
the the reporting has been around uh
some of his conversations also as we
anticipate a year full of Trials next
year so there's been so much speculation
contemplation discussion of what Trump
wanted to do what he knew or didn't know
I mean do you think as a prosecutor
former prosecutor this is something that
could be useful in the case against
Trump how will it be
used yeah well I mean look he says I
would be well received because he knows
that the people who were there are his
supporters who he riled up and incited
to invade riot at the capital and try to
disrupt the proper counting of the
Electoral College votes so every time he
talks he's uh putting himself into a
bigger criminal Hole uh but the but
that's not his objective his objective
is purely political at this point uh
politics don't work in a courtroom as I
think he's finding out in the New York
attorney general's case in New York a
civil case and and that's going to
continue in his criminal trials but his
rhetoric is really getting dangerous
more and more d dangerous and we saw
what happened on January 6th when he
uses inflammatory rhetoric now and his
recent true social post uh is incredibly
incredibly scary for anyone uh that
might be trying to op work in government
and um it is just uh unquestionable at
this point that that man cannot see
public office again he is not only unfit
he is destructive to our democ y uh and
he has to be uh he has to be
eliminated did I hear that last part
right there was a lot of talking before
that and I kind of fell asleep for a
minute but did did he say that the
former president of the United States
has to be eliminated that that seems a
bit over the top uh the same man who
just 20 seconds before that said that
his meaning Donald Trump's rck uh is
getting more and more dangerous then
called for Donald Trump to be eliminated
on
MSNBC on a show hosted by the former uh
press secretary for the current
president who has dementia and everyone
knows it and who also coordinated with
the government to silence people uh
during the election and during covid and
a whole bunch more uh I know that irony
is dead and I know that you know
comparing and contrasting the sides sort
of seem silly at points uh but try to
imagine if on Fox news last night there
was a congress man a republican
congressman who said that Joe Biden had
to be eliminated do you think there
would be a bit of an uproar today do you
think that would be the main story
everywhere you think you think but why
the harsh words why would Mr Goldman
over there be so upset about Donald
Trump and want to eliminate him uh well
I'm starting to think it's because that
the left can't compete if there's an
even playing field if social media is
equal if Main mream media is equal if
our ability to communicate with each
other is not hampered and manipulated by
these people then their ideas often fall
flat which is why they're always calling
to silence people and calling everyone
else a Nazi and a bigot and everything
else and actually now we are seeing some
statistical evidence of the trouble that
they are in uh because yes Trump is
beating Biden in a bunch of polls I
always say you have to take polls with a
grain of salt uh but look what's being
reported even in mainstream media media
now here it is Donald Trump we have at
46% Biden 44 and this is significant
because this is the first time in the
history of our poll that former
president Trump beats President Biden
still within the margin of error but
still significant yeah 2019 2020 when
Trump was President he trailed all of
them this year he's trailed all of them
in our poll first time in more than a
dozen polls we've seen a result like
this I like how they get that little
dorky guy with his mustard pants like
does he have any other outfit that guy
and he gets up there and oh my God the
numbers now look first of all if you're
Donald Trump and you're seeing those
numbers I know you're elated but on the
other hand if you also believe that they
stole the election from you last time
like two points I don't know if it means
that much but the greater Point here is
that's on Meet the Press that wasn't
MSNBC that's NBC's Sunday Meet the Press
the fact that they are now showing those
polls means they cannot deny the fact
that Biden's a struggling and it's
starting to kind of feel cool again to
support Donald Trump right like that's
clearly what's happening here and it
might also be a signal that the
corporate press is now trying as they've
been trying to do for a couple months I
would say uh trying to figure out a way
to give Biden the boot because obviously
no one thinks he's up to the job uh but
if you don't believe me on any of this
stuff if you don't believe me when it
comes to wait a minute Dave
surely the government couldn't have been
coordinating with big Tech to silence
people surely they wouldn't have done
that sort of thing it's the government
the government's good well the question
is do we have evidence do we have
evidence that they have been silencing
you that they have been coordinating
with big Tech to make sure that you
couldn't say what you want to say uh
well yeah because that very J saki you
remember this one this is from about two
years ago and she was very very upset at
the time that people were sharing
misinformation about covid there were
some people like Dave Rubin who said
that you know I don't know if the uh
vaccines work and I think mandates are
coming and I don't know that wearing a
mask does anything uh and Jen saki who
worked at the uh White House at the time
well here she is about what she felt
should happen if you're banned on one
social media platform uh providing uh
for for Facebook or other platforms to
measure and publicly share the impact of
misinformation on their platform uh and
the audience it's reaching uh also with
the public with all of you um to create
robust enforcement strategies that
bridge their properties and provide
transparency about rules you shouldn't
be banned from one platform and not
others uh if you for uh uh providing
misinformation out there now obviously
this is an old clip but you will see why
I'm connecting the dots for you on this
thing first off just the premise the
very premise of that the idea that
because one because you got banned on
Instagram for whatever reason you got
banned on Instagram that you should also
be banned on Facebook YouTube and
Twitter is is just completely bananas
but also what right does the government
have to tell these companies whether
they're public or private oh you were
banned there so make sure it's across
theboard Banning like it has absolutely
nothing to do with the government unless
call me crazy guys I think I'm onto
something here unless the government I
want to say this one out loud the
govern's been work social
medens
people so now I'm going to show
you
what was that like CU that to me that
was the most bizarre was the Twitter
files when you let shellenberger and
Matt taibe and all those guys get in the
tter and the response where mat taibe
gets audited I mean which is just wild
it's just so blatant and so in your face
yeah it's weird no I
mean the yeah the the degree to which
and and by the way Jack didn't really
know know this but the degree to which
Twitter was simply um an arm of the
government was not well understood by
the public and uh it was there was no it
was whatever the official government it
was like prda basically um you know it's
a state publication is the way to think
of old Twitter it's a state publication
and was the justification from their
perspective that they are progressive
liberals they have the right intentions
it's important that they stay in power
the progressive liberals stay in
government and power because this is the
this is their there was there was uh
basically oppression of
um any any views that would even I would
say be considered middle of the road um
but certainly anything on the the right
I'm not talking about like like far
right I'm just talking mildly right the
people like Republicans were suppressed
at 10 times the rate of Democrats um now
that's because uh old Twitter was
fundamentally controlled by the
farle it was like completely controlled
by the the farle by the way guys we now
know from just a couple weeks ago when
Congressman Jim Jordan uh released all
of those files that now they have tons
of emails and other evidence showing
that the government absolutely was
directing Twitter and some of the other
social media platforms to silence people
including me I my name was on the list
of the freaking thing so I want to jump
back to one other thing before we catch
up to uh to yesterday and what Elon is
doing right now because I'm sure some of
you remember this many of you remember
this I'm sure about a year ago I got an
call from somebody at Twitter and they
were like Elon would like to see you
today and I had to pull a gajillion
strings and I somehow was able to get on
a plane to show up to to Twitter
headquarters at literally I think I got
there at about 12:30 a.m. where he was
still taking meetings and everything
else uh and I put out a Twitter thread
after after spending a couple hours with
him over the course of two days
explaining what I saw there and I just
want to read you a short portion of that
because it's directly related to what's
going on right now spent last two days
at Twitter in San Francisco talking to
Engineers product managers and yes Elon
Musk learned a ton about what's going on
before I share I want to note that after
a couple hour meeting I asked Elon what
I could share and he said quote anything
that's true I met with several Engineers
who were doing a deep dive on why my
account and so many others seem to be
absolutely crushed after that two or 3
week return to normaly when Elon first
took over they still have more questions
than answers but they did learn a bunch
of stuff accounts aren't just hit with
labels that are obvious to insiders they
now found more secret labels which are
causing Shadow bands my account was hit
with all three recent abuse strike
recent misinformation strike recent
suspension strike so I mentioned that
guys just to to add a little color that
I have seen under the hood of how some
of this stuff operated I sat in a room
with a bunch of programmers who all
brought in their laptops and I saw the
the inside of Twitter and how they could
put strikes and how they were literally
going through the code and finding
things that were not obvious to them and
everything else and again if you're not
on Twitter as I always say God bless you
and you shouldn't be on there it's fine
it's a massive time suck and everything
else but we do need some tech companies
to be out there uh enabling us to
communicate with each other right right
most of you are watching this on YouTube
right now I could be taken off YouTube
like that I can't be taking off Rumble
like that so I hope that more of you and
I know more and more of you are watching
on Rumble which is just great and
watching on locals of course I want to
just read two other headlines related to
all this uh both from the daily wire
just in terms of what the government's
been up to when it comes to Twitter
specifically Twitter files part three
Twitter worked in coordination with US
government to censor content during 2020
election of course we all know that
that's related to Hunter Biden's laptop
which TW would not allow you to share
and then another one uh new Twitter
files show FBI paid Twitter Millions
influenced execs to censor Hunter Biden
laptop story okay so what is going on
here why am I doing all this old
backstory stuff well Elon has just about
had it from being attacked not only
actually by the government but also
these leftwing organizations that are
constantly going after him I want to
give you just one other uh sort of
subtext on this in terms of the growth
of Twitter this is from an account
demand Sage Twitter's year over
monetizable monthly active users from
2017 to today and now I think you'll see
why they're going at him so hard right
now 2017 they had 115 million users 2018
126 2019 152 2020 192 million 2021 229
million uh
2022 uh 20 sorry uh well then we'll jump
to 2023
[Music]
528.com it's tried to deplatform people
and make sure people couldn't get their
voices out and everything else now
they're going hardcore on Elon Musk so
we've got some info from the daily wire
ex-owner Elon Musk said on Saturday that
he would be filing a lawsuit against
leftist Outlet Media Matters for America
over a story it ran this week that said
he was misleading and intended to
undermine Free Speech the the Media
Matters story at the center of the suit
was published on Thursday and claimed
that X was placing ads for major
corporations alongside Nazi related
content in the aftermath of the story
multiple corporations said that they
would be pulling advertising from X
including apple and IBM a press release
from musk said that the media matter
story completely misrepresented the user
experience on X in another attempt to
undermine freedom of speech and mislead
advertisers musk said that X was
committed to free speech on the platform
even objectionable speech and that
people had the right to decide what to
read or watch despite our clear and
consistent position X has seen a number
of attacks from activist groups like
Media Matters and Legacy Media Outlets
who seek to undermine freedom of
expression on our platform because they
perceive it as a threat to their
ideological narrative and those of their
financial supporters the release said
mus said that Media Matters created a
contrived experience by using an
alternate account to curate what posts
appeared on the timeline once they
curated their feed they repeatedly
refreshed the timelines to find a rare
in of ads serving next to the content
they chose to follow musk said he said
that xlogs indicated that of the 5.5
billion ad impressions for the day Media
Matters pulled its research from that
less than 50 were served alongside
content highlighted by Media Matters for
one brand showcased in the article two
of its ads served adjacent two posts
three times and that ad was only seen in
that setting by one user the author of
The Media Matters article musk said so
to be very clear here guys because I
know it's a little uh it's a little
Insider baseball kind of stuff basically
Media Matters was creating fake accounts
curating the feeds so that it would
appear that ads from these companies
were showing up next to Nazi adjacent
content created by Media Matters in the
first place that is not to say there
aren't mean people on Twitter there are
mean people on Twitter people say
unbelievably horrible things to me all
day long I can mute them or block them
or get this one I don't have to look at
my phone all day I don't have to look at
responses it's really just wild I could
talk to real people Connor you want to
talk later we'll just shoot the you
could do that with other humans that's
pretty good too but anyway from this
absolutely fraudulent nonsense that
Media Matters is putting out there and
it's and if you've watched the show over
the last couple years it's fairly
obvious why they want to take Elon Musk
out and it's not because he's an
anti-semite or anything else right it's
because he's allowing other people to
speak and he's he's opening that Overton
window up just a bit more than the very
narrow way these Progressive
authoritarian lunatics would like it to
be open so from Mashable here's a couple
of the companies that have now cancelled
ads on Twitter Apple Comcast NBC
Universal Disney European Union IBM
Lionsgate entertainment Paramount Global
and Warner Brothers Discovery I mean
these are major major companies so what
actually is going on here well Joe benok
who's the head of business operations at
X he tweet this out to explain a bit
more about how Media Matters is
manipulating the system to get giant
companies to take their money out of
Twitter Media Matters created three
accounts and followed 30 accounts
similar to the one in the article they
then consistently refreshed the timeline
of post posts 13 times the number of ads
served to this user as opposed to the
median 50 impressions served against the
content in the article out of 5.5
billion served the whole day points to
the fact of how efficiently model avoids
content for ad advertisers data wins
over allegations uh and just one more on
the Twitter side this is from the new
Twitter CEO uh Linda Yaro who have a lot
of people had concerns about she wrote
if you know me you know I'm committed to
truth and fairness here's the truth not
a single authentic user on X saw ibms
concast or oracles ads next to the
content in Media Matters article only
two users saw Apple's ads
next to the content at least one of
which was Media Matters data wins over
manipulation or allegations don't me be
manipulated stand with X so now I want
to jump back one more time join me in
the DeLorean we're going to fill it up
with 1.21 gig of power flux capacitor
the whole thing we're going all the way
back all the way back now to May of 2019
because in May of 2019 uh this was
before I was fully supporting Donald
Trump but I was certainly on my way I
was leaving the left I was trying to
talk to people on other sides of the
political aisle and all of that stuff
and I tweeted to Pete Budaj who at that
time was running for president right
this is before he was uh Secretary of
Transportation unqualified Secretary of
Transportation uh I tweeted to Pete
budd's press secretary because I wanted
to sit down with him I had sat down with
Andrew yang had sat down with Tulsi gabt
I had sat down with a couple of the
other Democrat candidates no problem
treated everybody as respectfully as I
treat everybody else I tweeted at Pete
Budaj jud's press secretary and then he
asked me to contact him and now I want
to show you this from May of 2019 what
happened after that Media Matters Vox
and now Huffington Post are trying to
scare Pete Budaj away from an interview
with me I treat him with the exact same
decent decency and respect I've treated
every single one of my guests why is
that so scary to them so again I'm
trying to show you that these people
have been up to this for a long time and
it's not just Media Matters they work
through MSNBC they work through NBC they
work through Vox they work through
Rolling Stone they work through all of
these organizations so here's this guy
if we can go back to it this guy Carlos
Maza on Vox P budd's press secretary
reaching out to Dave Rubin Madness my
that's sheer Madness and then here's the
interesting one Angelo
kuson he is the CEO of Media Matters
this is the same guy going after Elon
now he still has the job he then tweeted
at Pete Budaj Jed's SE press secretary
and he wrote this hi Chris if you don't
know who cernovich is and why this is
probably not a good look for the mayor
feel free to visit mediamatters.org or
just DM me and I'd be happy to share now
the reason cernovich is involved in this
is because I the week before I asked PE
to come on I had Mike cernovich on Mike
cernovich is on the right Pete budajudge
was on the left I was trying to talk to
everybody but Media Matters started
using their pressure to make sure that a
presidential candidate would not come on
my show one more this is from a guy
Nathan Bernard who also is and was at
Media Matters listen to this one Dave
Rubin a useful idiot who interviews
White nationalists on YouTube is
chatting with serial rapists and
pizzagate prop this weird mic today this
is yet another example of the
intellectual dark web platforming
streaming in the name of free speech I
have no idea I've never heard anything
about Mike cernovich being a serial
rapist I don't know what white
nationalists I've ever sat with oh and
here's another one this is from
Huffington Post a guy named Andy
Campbell this podcast is starting to
look like a bad idea for Buddha jedge ah
and we got one more should we throw
another one no that's it right we'll
we'll leave it at that the point of all
of this the point of all of this is do
you see see how they coordinate and
they've been doing this for years so I
found that old tweet of mine and I
tweeted it at Elon Musk I said the CEO
going after me back then is the same guy
going after Elon now and Elon saw it
this is just yesterday and said they
they are dirty tricks for hirees so
again I really I hope you understand
this I'm not trying to make this about
me I am just trying to show you guys
that all of us and again I was I was not
even a trump supporter at that point
right like what they have tried to do is
make sure that anyone who does not bow
down to them cannot even talk to other
people like Pete Budaj right it
obviously would have been an interesting
conversation to have me talk to Pete
Budaj obviously and everyone knows I
would have treated him the same way but
they not only does Media Matters put
pressure on political campaigns right
and then of course P judge never came on
the show they never responded to me they
they the guy gave me his email address
we reached out and they just went cold
so Media Matters pressured a
presidential candidate to not do my show
it gets proliferated through Huffington
Post through Vox all of these other
things which are far-left organizations
that get all kinds of crazy money from
George Soros types yes it's true with
Vox and a bunch of other people and then
they degrade the ability for us as a
society to honestly discuss anything
anyway uh the Media Matters uh CEO
Angelo kuson uh if I I think I'm getting
his name right maybe Kyro son uh he the
same guy who did not want me there he is
there he is uh this is uh him on MSNBC
yesterday continuing to go after Elon
and Twitter that the platform is so
saturated with extremism with white
genocide with anti-Semitism with racism
with conspiracy theories things that
otherwise should be managed in some way
that they can't actually protect the few
brands that are still willing to remain
on the platform and this has actually
been an ongoing thing for the last few
months this is just the latest and
actually a string of these instances so
I think the most important thing though
was that he confirmed that we were right
oh so Media Matters and Angelo they're
very very concerned about all the hate
on Twitter now it's funny because before
Elon got Twitter they weren't worried
about that right they there was plenty
of hate on Twitter I used to get a ton
of hate from the left when say I left
the left and I would have progressives
telling me to kill myself and that they
were going to come kill me and a whole
bunch more they didn't really care about
that but they are making it clear that
Elon Musk is Enemy Number One and again
why is he Enemy Number One well it
linked back to everything we covered
earlier it links back to that
conversation with Joe Rogan that Twitter
before Elon was basically a a an
apparatus of the government to silence
anyone who did not fall in line with
leftist Orthodoxy Media Matters right
now has a page devoted to Elon look at
that scar oh my God there's all the
pictures of him and he's got x's and his
sunglasses it's all very he's very scary
scary
man but I thought let's do a little bit
of a deep dive on Media Matters these
people don't seem to like me I'm a nice
guy they don't seem to like Elon he
seems okay what is the deal with Media
Matters well there's a Twitter account
Travis in Flint he did a bit of a dive
on Media Matters and the creator of
Media Matters he wrote this meet David
Brock the founder of the far-left group
Media Matters Brock was an avid
conservative in the 9s and even exposed
Bill Clinton which led to a lawsuit
against Clinton then like magic
something switched he immediately became
Hillary's biggest biggest supporter out
of nowhere he went so far in 2001 that
he even exposed his Source in the
Clinton scandal he was all in on Bill
and Hillary after switching sides he
decided to announce that he had risen
above character attacks instead it
appears he's decided to attack and
Destroy anything that goes against the
Clinton
in 2004 he founded Media Matters since
then it appears the main goal has been
nonstop attacks on every one of
Clinton's enemies some of his employees
were complaining in 2016 that the entire
company had shifted into Hillary's PR
firm this man wants the world to believe
he's a changed man and a good person but
the reality is he's made his career out
of completely destroying his enemies
he's met his match now Elon Musk is
going to give him the fame he's always
wanted but not in a good way I can't
wait to see how this lawsuit plays out
who's ready for the thermonuclear
lawsuits to drop now I cannot speak to
the absolute veracity of the claims
right there other than to say that David
Brock who was in the Clinton world and
now is somehow a big Lefty after being a
conservative for sure is the one behind
all of this he put this
organization together so speaking of
thermonuclear drops here's a tweet from
Elon Musk this is from over the weekend
and yes it has happened the Split Second
Court opens on Monday excp will be
filing a thermonuclear lawsuit against
Media Matters and all those who colluded
in this fraudulent attack on our
company all right pretty good and
obviously you're seeing a whole bunch
there here's a bit of the statement this
week Media Matters for America posted a
story that completely misrepresented the
real user experience on X in another
attempt to undermine freedom of speech
and mislead advertisers above everything
including profit X Works to protect the
Public's right to free speech but for
speech to be truly free we must also
have freedom to see or hear things that
some people may consider objectionable
we believe that everyone has the right
to make up their own minds about what to
read watch or listen to Because that's
the power of freedom of speech despite
our clear and consistent positions X has
seen a number of attacks from activist
groups like Media Matters and Legacy
Media Outlets who seek to undermine
freedom of expression on our platform
because they perceive it as a threat to
their ideological narrative and those of
their financial supporters these groups
try to use their influence to attack our
revenue streams by deceiving advertisers
on X here are the facts on Media Matters
research to manipulate the public and
advertisers Media Matters created an
alternate account and curated the posts
and advertising appearing on the
accounts timeline to misinform
advertisers about the placement of their
posts these contrived experiences could
be applied to any platform once they
curated their feed they repeatedly
refreshed their timelines to find a rare
instance of ads serving next to the
content they chose to follow our logs
indicate that they forced a scenario
resulting in 13 times the number of ads
served compared to the median ads served
to an xuser of the 5.5 billion ad
Impressions on X that day less than 50
total ad Impressions were served against
all of the organic content featured in
the Media Matters article for one brand
showcased in the article one of its ads
ran adjacent to a post two times and
that ad was seen in that setting by only
two users one of which was the author of
the media matters article for another
brand Showcase in the article two of its
ads served adjacent to two posts three
times and that ad was only seen in that
setting by one user the author of The
Media Matters article we're almost there
guys Media Matters article also
highlights nine posts they believe
should not be allowed on X upon
evaluation only one of the nine organic
posts featured in the article violated
our content policy and we've taken
action under it under our freedom of
speech not reach enforcement approach
here's a summary on all of this X will
protect the Public's right to free
expression we will not allow agenda
agenda-driven activists or even our own
profits to deter our vision everyone has
a choice on X users and Brands control
uh users and Brands controls on X are
superior to a year ago data wins over
allegations Media Matters does not
reflect the user experience on X as
we've seen in some parts of the world
when free expression is taken away it is
very dangerous and hard to get back
that's why the people who came before us
fought so hard to protect
without freedom of speech we lose the
checks and balances critical to a
thriving democracy we defend our
individual rights as if our lives and
our flourishing Society depend on it if
you're really in on protecting Free
Speech then we all need to protect it
completely stand with x in order to
protect Free Speech ladies and gentlemen
um is it obvious to you who the good
guys and bad guys are right now like
it's pretty obvious right like Elon Musk
fought this thing for $44 billion it is
purging money he is losing every day he
is losing I don't know what he's losing
every day like it it literally could be
millions of dollars every day the code
was screwed up he had activists working
there they had government agents working
there even right now I'm fairly certain
if you've talked to him if you talked to
him today he would say he's not exactly
sure how many Bad actors are still at
the company right now but is it not
fairly obvious after covid after Hunter
by and laptop after election stuff after
January 6 after all of the stuff isn't
it fairly obvious that this guy bought
this thing to just make sure a few more
of us would be able to see what the
truth is and get our ideas out there
even if you were only to look if you
remove all of the the specifics that I
just mentioned all those incidences even
if you were only to look at what has
happened since October 7th or the the
horrific incidences the horrific facts
of October 7th Twitter was the main
place that they were shared right do you
would you have left it up to Facebook or
YouTube or elsewhere to make sure that
people would have been able to see the
the horrific uh attacks that Hamas
perpetrated no of course Twitter allowed
for that that is what this is all about
right now the fight that is happening
right now is a fight for us to have any
ability to know what is true it is
getting harder hard and harder it's
getting harder not only for you guys
it's getting harder for me we are being
manipulated in ways we cannot imagine
but we must go on offense and that's why
I dedicated Today's Show to this it is
not to say that I agree with Elon Musk
on any everything or he's right about
everything but he's going on offense and
we have to defend the people who will
Who will put their butts on the line the
guy doesn't have to do this he could get
on a rocket today and go to Mars that's
pretty cool I might join him on that if
possible
uh but if they are going to relentlessly
attack us and relentlessly attack
everything that we that is held dear to
us then we must attack them back uh and
actually that is what's happening uh
right now in Texas another tweet from
Colin rug just in just moments after X
launched a thermonuclear lawsuit against
left-wing Media Matters Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton announced an
investigation into Media Matters for
fraudulent activity this is what holding
the media accountable looks like the
Office of the Attorney General is
opening an investigation into Media
Matters for potential fraudulent
activity the letter said we are
examining the issue closely to ensure
that the public has not been deceived by
the schemes of radical left-wing
organizations who would like nothing
more than to limit Freedom by reducing
participation in the Public Square
attorney general Paxton said this is big
this is big and you know what happens
when somebody starts being brave right
we talk about this all the time when
somebody starts being brave others
people start being brave because you see
oh my God that guy said something and
it's right and it's true and yes some
mean people said some mean things about
him but he's still standing there so
maybe I should get on in on this and I'm
very proud to say uh that Rumble is
getting in on this so Chris pavlovski
who is my friend and obviously the CEO
of Rumble said uh he retweeted Elon when
it regarding the the law suit and he
said when I said the Cavalry is coming I
was not joking in the coming days we are
going thermonuclear as well everyone is
about to witness the greatest push back
against the censorship regime the
people's support for all organizations
in this mission is critical one more
from Chris pavlovski because he's
feeling it right now and I can tell you
and having known Chris for quite some
time right now uh he doesn't burn very
hot you got to push this guy uh to
really go hot and he really has one more
from him the tide has turned offense
only from now on so yes X is in on this
push back Rumble is in on it which means
locals is in on it and we are going to
we are going to push and fight as hard
as we can and all we need are other good
people to offer defense and occasionally
go on offense when they can I want to
show you one more uh throwback I think
we've shown this to you once or twice of
Elon talking about why he bought Twitter
in the first place and do you think that
maybe this is connected to everything
that we're talking about today what was
it ultimately that led you to make the
decision to do
it I mean this is going to sound uh
somewhat melodramatic but I was worried
about that that it was having a
corrosive effect on
civilization uh that it was uh just
having a bad a bad impact um
and
um I think part of it is that it's where
it's where it was located which is uh
you know downtown San Francisco um and
while I I think San Francisco is a
beautiful city and and we should really
fight hard to um kind of write the ship
of San Francisco if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the
xfk Twitter headquarters it's a zombie
apocalypse I mean it's rough have you
have you been been in that area not
lately no I've heard it's crazy I've
heard it's crazy I've heard you you
really can't believe it until you
actually go there you can't believe it
until you go there so now you have to
say well what philosophy led to that
outcome and that philosophy was being
piped to
Earth so um you know a philosophy that
would be ordinarily quite Niche and
geographically constrained so the that
sort of the fallout area would be
limited um was effectively given an
information
weapon um a tech Information Technology
weapon to
propagate uh what is essentially a mind
virus to the rest of both um and the
outcome of that mind virus is very clear
if you walk around the streets of
downtown San Francisco it is the end of
civilization that's Elon at his best
right like listen to how calmly and
cleanly he is explaining what's going on
there and how he's connecting what he
was seeing on the streets of s San
Francisco and I can vouch for that
personally because I stood up in his
corner office up there with the windows
going both ways with Elon looking down
and he was talking about where they get
the drugs where they do the drugs that's
where they're all beating the crap out
of each other and all of that stuff but
what he's saying is that this Niche
ideology meaning the collectivist
ideology what we now all know as as
wokeism which is really just
collectivism with a dash of racism and a
dash of gender confusion and all of that
it was it's a niche ideology that would
have been left in certain Geographic
places throughout time right like there
would have been little pockets of it
here and there but it was weaponized by
big Tech and then the government and
then through algorithmic tricks it was
pushed everywhere which leads us to
exactly where we are at the moment but
as you know good people find a way to
get out of this madness so as we covered
yesterday there is a new president in
Argentina jav Vier Malay and he is now
the president of Argentina because they
have had massive government growth
complete devaluation of their currency
they have had a creeping socialism for a
long time craziness with gender stuff
and all of the woke stuff and he has
come into absolutely
obliterated and listen to him uh talking
about why you must fight the Socialists
and the wers and the people who want
that ever encroaching government which
is directly connected to what Elon just
said Donald Trump is running for
president again in the United States as
you know what advice would you give
him
me
you get it you get it so the people of
San Francisco the people of California
they let it in they let it spread they
didn't fight most of the people elected
the very people who ushered it all in
Argentina after 20 years of this
nonsense is pushing back Donald Trump
was pushing pushing back there are
Pockets places like Florida that are
pushing back you should be pushing back
and might I suggest that we all go a bit
more on offense that has been the Ruben
report program for today uh in about uh
hour 15 we'll be live people of the
internet as always if you want to join
us Ruben report. locals.com if you want
to call in and talk to me and uh we
leave you since Javier is doing it he's
really feeling it right now we leave you
with a little Javier and postgame show
coming up in about 30 seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
ciao